[Music]
a developing story in henderson tonight
police arrest two people for
random shooting at people in the city
killing one
thank you for joining us tonight at 11
i'm brian loftis this all happened at a
7 11
right near warm springs in lake mead
parkway 8 news now's david charns is
live at the scene with what we know
right now david
well brian some new details tonight
we've learned that this all ended with
an officer involved shooting in
arizona about 200 miles away from here
this all started around one o'clock this
morning when henderson police
say they started getting calls from
people saying they had been shot at
and it ended here at this 7-eleven
parking lot
on east lake mead where a 22 year old
man died now he was shot and killed here
four other people
also shot but they are expected to
survive
after the shooting police tell us they
began looking for a man and a woman in a
car with
tattoos or paint on their faces
investigators believe the pair was
simply driving around
and shooting at random people now at
some point they drove into arizona where
they're expected
of even more shooting suspected of those
shootings
there was some sort of altercation with
police there
and there was another shooting now
police tell us no troopers were hurt but
three people were involved in that
officer involved shooting and all three
of them were arrested
but it's unclear if there was a third
person in the car during these drive-by
shootings by this drive-by shooting here
in henderson
now back here live this now marks the
13th homicide
in henderson this year alone no names
have been released for either the victim
who was killed here or the suspects we
do expect to get more information
tomorrow of course we'll pass that along
both on air
and online live in henderson tonight i'm
david charns 8 news now